there's one food that you must avoid
in order to overcome Alzheimer's in fact
I don't think you can actually even
improve Alzheimer's symptoms if you
continue to consume this one food with
Alzheimer's we have this fire going on
in the brain we have inflammation
amyloid plaquing neurofibrillary Tangles
which is basically like this big ball of
fishing line that develops right after
the plaquing so they both work together
and then the immune reaction to that
creates a tremendous amount of
inflammation and all these neurons start
dying but of all the factors that can
influence Alzheimer's positive or
negative
what you eat is the most important thing
here's some information that you
probably have never heard before insulin
is neural protective it actually
protects your brain cell it actually
prevents this amyloid plaquing from
developing and it also prevents the
accumulation of those Tangled type
fibers that I just mentioned there's
even therapies that certain doctors use
called intranasal insulin sprays where
they actually spray insulin up your
sinuses so they go right into the brain
and it's been proven that it increases
memory and the ability to learn so one
big factor relating to insulin is that
if you're deficient in insulin uh your
risk for getting amyloid plaquing goes
up what increases insulin carbs
so should we start eating carbs okay is
that going to help the situation no
because carbs raise blood sugars
and people with high blood sugar like
diabetics have a much higher risk of
getting Alzheimer's so this is confusing
because carbs increase insulin and that
should naturally prevent you from
getting Alzheimer's but it actually
causes Alzheimer's this is why some
people coin the term type 3 diabetes is
Alzheimer's okay here's the missing
information when you increase insulin
you instantly create
resistance the body starts to protect
you against this excess insulin and it
leads to insulin resistance okay
when you have insulin resistance you
actually have a deficiency of insulin
inside your cells so more insulin
creates a deficiency of insulin sounds
strange sounds counterintuitive but now
you know why because the body forms this
protective mechanism
which is insulin resistance and as far
as how this relates to alzheimer's you
have the blood-brain barrier okay that
can actually be resistant to insulin now
even though the brain does make a little
bit of insulin majority of the brain's
insulin is dependent on what's Happening
throughout the body so just as a
diabetic develops insulin resistance
throughout the body the brain can also
develop insulin resistance as well
especially in the blood brain barrier so
insulin resistance is the most important
thing you need to understand so many
people don't understand this and they're
unknowingly making things worse
by feeding their parents and
grandparents the wrong food because the
number one thing that will increase
insulin is carbs okay I'm not talking
about vegetable carbohydrates I'm
talking about sugars and I'm talking
about refined grains and I'm talking
about grains as well yeah breads pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes
muffins juice desserts all these things
will absolutely positively make things
worse you can't fix Alzheimer's on top
of these carbs it's impossible you must
fix insulin resistance the carbs aren't
the only thing that creates a spike in
insulin okay
and by the way when you fix instant
resistance
the neurons finally get the level of
insulin that they need to help this
neural protection and decrease the
inflammation now carbs in general
especially in the refined form and
sugars create a tremendous amount of
inflammation too in the brain that's in
addition to the insulin problem all
these carbs also create a lot of
mitochondrial damage okay which destroy
the mitochondria which is the energy to
the neuron itself and also at the same
time creating a lot of oxidation and for
radical damage and a lowered ability to
deal with that because consuming a lot
of sugars and refined carbs decrease
your antioxidants so we have all this
inflammation without any ability to
counter the inflammation so what is the
most important thing you can do if you
have a loved one that has Alzheimer's or
you are starting to develop symptoms for
Alzheimer's is to understand this
mechanism and fix insulin resin distance
and there are several ways to do it okay
number one you must lower your carbs so
you can start shifting your your body
running on ketones which is a preferred
better more efficient fuel to the brain
cells
so if you get a ketone meter you want to
make sure you're in ketosis I'm talking
about 0.5 to 3 millimoles that would be
the level that you want to shoot for now
you can also increase those ketones by
doing some other cool things like adding
exercise and adding fasting which I
think you should do as well but the
point is if there's damage in the brain
from this insulin problem and this
glucose problem thank goodness there's
another pathway you can actually start
feeding the brain cells so any patient
who has Alzheimer's must be feeding
their brain cells ketones if they want
any chance of turning things around okay
so that's number one getting on the
ketogenic diet the next thing you need
to know about insulin resistance to be
able to fix it is that the frequency of
meals okay the more times you eat and
snack the more you're going to raise
insulin okay so you also must do
intermittent fasting and if you have
signs of Alzheimer's okay or you're at
risk you really need to be on what's
called omad which is one meal a day that
meal needs to be healthy and it needs to
be big enough and providing you with all
the nutrition but allowing your body to
fast for 23 hours is super super
important because you're going to keep
your insulin low you're going to
actually start to allow the neurons to
be fed with insulin you're going to turn
around insulin resistance so much faster
so the worse someone has Alzheimer's the
less frequent they should eat and you
would see a dramatic Improvement if you
did this so one meal a day and make sure
that meal is the ketogenic diet well I'm
57 years old I'm six foot two I weigh
185 pounds and I can easily run my body
on one meal a day okay I have more
calories but my body does very very well
on that so anyone that is over the age
of 50 really should be considering uh
one meal a day simply because we don't
need so many calories especially if
you're not doing hardcore workouts and
if you talk about Alzheimer's patients
which are not typically active or
they're in a home or Assisted Living I
mean they're not burning out these
calories to feed them more than one meal
a day is completely unnecessary and
unfortunately they're usually getting
three meals a day plus snacks completely
way too much food because anytime you
have insulin resistance you're going to
be craving carbs and you're going to be
hungry all the time
but as soon as you do one meal a day you
convert the body over to ketones and the
hunger goes away and the Cravings go
away and it makes it really easy to do
and the fourth thing is to make sure
that meal is really healthy and nutrient
dense the next thing to know do whatever
you can to lower stress stress activates
cortisol another name for cortisol is
glucocorticoids which has to do with
glucose so in other words anytime you
increase cortisol you increase glucose
and not because you're eating sugar just
because your body's in a stressed state
that can create insulin resistance that
can create even diabetes so people that
go through stress chronically or they're
taking prednisone or some type of
synthetic cortisone for pain wow it's
like eating sugar there's a lot of
things you can do I just want you to get
the concept you want to lower this
stress the points I just mentioned are
like a requirement from any plan if
you're trying to turn this Alzheimer's
around and the next most important video
to watch would be that video I did on
what to eat okay what would that one
meal a day consist of to be healthy and
I put that video up right here check it
out